know you hear the pleas all the time
police safety advocates are all trying
to get drivers and pedestrians to be
more aware on the road as the time
changes and it gets darker earlier
bianca holman explains how those pleas
are getting louder
i always thought this was something that
happened on the news this happened to
somebody else but it happened to me it
happened to my family susan smith lost
her 12-year-old son johnny in 2019 to a
speeding driver it could have been
prevented had he been going 35 as the
speed limit was posted he would not have
hit my son he would have been able to
stop in time speed impairment and
darkness are major factors in pedestrian
deaths and fatal crashes the recent
fatal crash involving raiders player
henry ruggs is a situation advocates
describe as preventable pedestrian
fatalities in clark county have reached
the 2019 total and with two more months
remaining the total might reach the 2020
total of 64. we live in a community
where we encourage people to party to
have a good time
and
that's great as long as you don't get
behind the wheel of a car
and as long as you're not trying to
navigate yourself across the street
clark county leaders want people on foot
to wear reflective gear and stay alert
as we change to daylight savings time
and drivers they want them to be more
cautious as most people will be
commuting home in the dark bianca holmen
live local now